Shure:  几点了哥
Shure: What time is it, bro?
Shure:  10点了还写毕设呢
Shure: It's 10 o'clock and you're still working on your thesis?
Katrina:  那没别的时间呀
Katrina: There's no other time.
Katrina:  早上起不来
Katrina: I can't get up in the morning.
Katrina:  只有晚上工作
Katrina: I can only work at night.
Shure:  明天早上我叫你
Shure: I'll wake you up tomorrow morning.
Shure:  咱俩一起写毕设
Shure: We'll work on the thesis together.
Katrina:  好吧
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  几点钟
Katrina: What time?
Shure:  8点钟起写毕设
Shure: Start working at 8.
Shure:  你写不写
Shure: Are you in?
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Shure: 我现在
Shure: I'm serious.
Shure:  咱再来一杯
Shure: Let's have another drink.
Shure:  然后咱8点起来写毕设
Shure: Then we'll get up at 8 and work on the thesis.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Deal?
Katrina:  不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  坚定原则
Katrina: Stick to principles.
Shure:  咦好坚定
Shure: Wow, so firm.
Katrina:  等我今天把事弄完了
Katrina: Let me finish up today first.
Katrina:  明天跟你喝
Katrina: Let's drink together tomorrow.
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  第第二天
Katrina: It's the second day.
Katrina:  还早着呢
Katrina: It's still early.
Katrina:  明天还要拍那个yesok
Katrina: We have to shoot that "yesok" thing tomorrow.
Katrina:  yesok
Katrina: Yesok.
Katrina:  你今天晚上去学
Katrina: You go learn it tonight.
Katrina:  你来教行吗
Katrina: Can you teach me?
Katrina:  不想教
Katrina: I don't want to teach.
Shure:  我可以给你查拍子
Shure: I can help you keep time.
Shure:  我查拍子绝对牛逼
Shure: I'm really good at keeping time.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Nicous: 你他妈也太浪费钱了吧
Nicous: You're wasting money, you know that?
Nicous: 抽这么一点就扔你是人吗
Nicous: You smoke a little and throw it away, are you even human?
Shure:  怎么遭哇
Shure: What's wrong with that?
Katrina:  哦也是你们帮忙挑的
Katrina: Oh, you guys helped pick it out too.
Katrina:  他的优势是
Katrina: His advantage is
Nicous: 两个客厅大
Nicous: The two big living rooms.
Nicous:  公共区域比较大
Nicous: The common area is pretty big.
Nicous: 他还有一个优势是每个人住的地方比较大
Nicous: Another advantage is that everyone has a lot of space.
Katrina:  嗯我当时
Katrina: Hmm, at that time
Katrina:  我当时一直以为是三个人住一个房间
Katrina: I always thought three people lived in one room.
Nicous:  差点让你们三个人住一个房间
Nicous: Almost had you three in one room.
Shure:  为什么不是三个人住一个房间
Shure: Why not three people in one room?
Nicous:  那你就跟杨老板住一个房间
Nicous: Then you'd be rooming with Jake.
Nicous:  不是三个人是两两
Nicous: It's not three people, it's pairs.
Katrina:  他5点睡
Katrina: He sleeps at 5.
Katrina:  你几点睡
Katrina: When do you sleep?
Shure:  我以为是跟女嘉宾住一个房间
Shure: I thought I was rooming with a female guest.
Katrina:  这话赶紧给他录下来
Katrina: Quickly record what he said.
Katrina:  给他女朋友发过去
Katrina: Send it to his girlfriend.
Shure:  你滚犊子吧你
Shure: Get lost, you.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  哎你知道吗
Shure: Hey, do you know?
Shure:  我我们俩
Shure: We, the two of us
Shure:  我俩五一一一起回长春你知道吗
Shure: The two of us are going back to Changchun for May Day, you know?
Katrina:  那这不得见一波家长啊
Katrina: Then you have to meet the parents.
Nicous: 所以酒喝多了都可以说了
Nicous: So when you're drunk, you can say anything.
Nicous: 你妈说你妈说终于能见到小红帽了
Nicous: Your mom said, "Finally meeting Little Red Riding Hood."
Shure:  你知道这个小红帽子梗吗
Shure: Do you know the Little Red Riding Hood joke?
Katrina:  啊我室友也是
Katrina: Ah, my roommate too.
Katrina:  就是男生的妈妈来找他
Katrina: His mom came to look for him.
Nicous: 因为她不理我了
Nicous: Because she ignored me.
Katrina:  对就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  但是但是
Katrina: But, but
Katrina:  这样子的话也有有好也有不好
Katrina: In this case, it has both good and bad sides.
Katrina:  那要是你以后换女朋友
Katrina: What if you change girlfriends later?
Katrina:  你妈不得哄下一个
Katrina: Your mom has to coax the next one.
Shure:  我本我本来买的那个杭州
Shure: I originally bought the ticket to Hangzhou.
Shure:  直接去长春的那个高铁票
Shure: The high-speed train ticket directly to Changchun.
Katrina:  你女朋友啊
Katrina: Your girlfriend?
Katrina:  哎呀你们俩够抽象的
Katrina: Oh, you two are quite abstract.
Katrina:  不是你你们俩
Katrina: No, you two
Katrina:  呃你们俩就那个软件上认识以后
Katrina: You two met on the app?
Katrina:  那见面了吗
Katrina: So, did you meet in person?
Katrina:  然后见面就表白在一起了
Katrina: And then you confessed and got together?
Katrina:  他给你写的
Katrina: He wrote it for you.
Katrina:  感觉每个人的事情都很神奇
Katrina: It feels like everyone's story is so magical.
Katrina:  那就是见面了的时候
Katrina: So, when you met
Katrina:  就互相彼此心动了呗
Katrina: You both just got attracted to each other.
Katrina:  看对眼了呗
Katrina: You just liked each other.
Katrina:  哦确实一开始就眼熟嘛
Katrina: Oh, you did recognize each other from the start.
Katrina:  你不是说很抽象吗你这个
Katrina: Didn't you say it was very abstract?
Katrina:  特别喜欢听别人讲八卦
Katrina: I really love hearing gossip.
Katrina:  因为我在学校圈子其实就我舍
Katrina: Because in my school circle, it's just my dorm mates.
Katrina:  友然后我舍友几个要么就有男朋友
Katrina: Some of my dorm mates have boyfriends.
Katrina:  一直高中谈到现在
Katrina: They've been dating since high school.
Katrina:  要么就是不跟男的说一句话
Katrina: Others don't talk to boys at all.
Katrina:  就没有没有八卦就是我说我
Katrina: So there's no gossip. I mean, my social circle at school is pretty small.
Katrina:  我在学校里圈子比较小
Katrina: I don't hear any gossip.
Katrina:  就没听见什么八卦
Katrina: We just love meeting new people.
Katrina:  我们哎太喜欢认识新的人了
Katrina: We really enjoy it.
Shure:  我们想想听你的八卦
Shure: We want to hear your gossip.
Katrina:  我就一段
Katrina: I just have one story.
Nicous: 说宝宝早安
Nicous: Say good morning, baby.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You...
Katrina:  你跟你前女友官宣
Katrina: You and your ex-girlfriend made it official.
Katrina:  暧昧
Katrina: Flirting.
Nicous:  一开始暧昧
Nicous: It started with flirting.
Nicous:  后来已经g了
Nicous: Then it ended.
Nicous:  后来他私信不理我
Nicous: Then she stopped replying to my DMs.
Nicous:  他说他在忙
Nicous: She said she was busy.
Nicous:  然后我以为我跟他就是朋友处了
Nicous: I thought we were just friends.
Nicous:  然后我就直接跟
Nicous: Then I met my ex-girlfriend.
Nicous:  然后后来就跟我前女友认识了
Nicous: Then we got to know each other.
Nicous:  就是不认识了
Nicous: We didn't know each other before.
Katrina:  也就是说
Katrina: So you're saying...
Katrina:  你跟你现女友认识的比你前女友早
Katrina: You met your current girlfriend before your ex-girlfriend.
Nicous: 早太多了
Nicous: Way earlier.
Nicous:  然后然后我就直接发过来
Nicous: Then, then I just sent it over.
Nicous:  我也没隐瞒他我就他看见了
Nicous: I didn't hide it, she saw it.
Nicous:  然后他就说好吧然后
Nicous: Then she said, "okay."
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Nicous:  过了一段时间过了一段时间
Nicous: After a while, after a while...
Nicous:  他买了个机票直接来北京
Nicous: She bought a ticket and came to Beijing.
Nicous:  他然后他到了晚上跟我讲他到了
Nicous: She arrived and told me she was here.
Nicous:  让我晚上出来接他
Nicous: Asked me to pick her up at night.
Katrina:  但是那时你分手了吗
Katrina: But had you broken up by then?
Nicous:  没分的我刚来北京
Nicous: I didn't get any points, I just arrived in Beijing.
Nicous:  然后关键最惆怅的是我他妈睡着了
Nicous: And the worst part is, I freaking fell asleep.
Nicous:  没看见嗯我刚起来他飞走了吧哦
Nicous: I didn't see it, I just woke up and it flew away, right?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Katrina:  但是我觉得这女生还蛮有勇气的
Katrina: But I think that girl was pretty brave.
Nicous:  然后后来就都互删了
Nicous: Then we just deleted each other.
Katrina:  互删了后来又加上了
Katrina: Deleted each other, but then added back later.
Nicous:  后来我女朋友老出轨
Nicous: Later, my girlfriend kept cheating on me.
Nicous:  我就不想跟我女朋友谈了
Nicous: So I didn't want to be with her anymore.
Nicous:  但是我就把他加回来了
Nicous: But I added her back.
Nicous:  然后但是那时候没想跟他谈恋爱
Nicous: But I didn't want to date her at that time.
Nicous:  我一直都是加回来了
Nicous: I just added her back.
Nicous:  然后抱歉一下干嘛
Nicous: Then I apologized or something.
Katrina:  但是你那也有点像就
Katrina: But that seems a bit like...
Katrina:  在他的视角有点像断崖式暧昧耶
Katrina: From his perspective, it feels like a sudden flirtation.
Katrina:  就是本来暧昧很好的然后突然跟别人
Katrina: Like it was going well, then suddenly with someone else.
Katrina:  四天四天就能代表什么
Katrina: Four days, what can four days represent?
Shure:  四天我这四年里
Shure: Four days, in my four years...
Katrina:  我这五年的
Katrina: In my five years...
Shure:  不喝点了吗
Shure: Haven't you had a drink?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  你给我整点呗
Katrina: Get me some.
Shure:  给你整点
Shure: Get you some.
Katrina:  你当心他进去了
Katrina: Be careful, he's coming in.
Nicous: 当时我加他的时候我就跟他说了
Nicous: When I added her, I told her.
Nicous: 就我之前不想跟她谈一方面是家境悬殊
Nicous: One reason I didn't want to date her before was the huge gap in our family backgrounds.
Katrina:  他家很有钱吗
Katrina: Is her family very rich?
Nicous: 我靠他他妈随便买个包都好多万
Nicous: Man, she can casually buy a bag worth tens of thousands.
Katrina:  我去那确实有点啊
Katrina: Wow, that's really something.
Katrina:  那确实
Katrina: That really is.
Katrina:  那你这飞机飞来飞去
Katrina: And you were flying back and forth.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  就是在一直就跟他在一起
Katrina: You were always together.
Katrina:  就是我靠你都同居还能出轨哈哈哈
Katrina: I mean, wow, you were living together and she still cheated, haha.
Katrina:  我靠你给我少搞一点点
Katrina: Wow, you better tone it down a bit.
Katrina:  你前女友是表演型人格吗
Katrina: Was your ex-girlfriend a histrionic personality?
Katrina:  啊你俩谁也不缺啊
Katrina: Ah, neither of you are lacking.
Katrina:  他分了你也分了
Katrina: She broke up, you broke up.
Katrina:  然后你俩在一起了
Katrina: And then you two got together.
Katrina:  怎么不算一种缘分呢
Katrina: How is that not a kind of fate?
Katrina:  我靠你给我搞这么多东西
Katrina: Oh my gosh, you got me so much stuff.
Katrina:  晚上要一直上厕所
Katrina: I'll be going to the bathroom all night.
Nicous: 我初恋在我初二的时候
Nicous: My first love was in my second year of middle school.
Katrina:  看柚子好不好喝哈
Katrina: Try this grapefruit, see if it's good.
Katrina:  哎还行
Katrina: Oh, it's alright.
Katrina:  感觉比橙汁好喝
Katrina: I think it tastes better than orange juice.
Shure:  他那个西柚和橙汁
Shure: His grapefruit and orange juice
Shure:  都是比较比较不错的
Shure: are both pretty good.
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who dares to disturb my utopia?
Shure:  我马上掏出我的枪
Shure: I'll pull out my gun right away.
Nicous: 我就是上了大学才觉得我初中那些不是事
Nicous: It was only when I got to college that I realized those middle school things didn't matter.
Shure: 知道这这首叫什么吗
Shure: Do you know what this song is called?
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who dares to disturb my utopia?
Shure:  我马上掏出我的枪
Shure: I'll pull out my gun right away.
Shure:  初中的时候
Shure: Back in middle school,
Alice: 这有个找个小瑕疵
Alice: There's a small flaw here.
Nicous: 我当时觉得我已经略微的
Nicous: At that time, I thought I had somewhat
Katrina: 定了
Katrina: settled it.
Nicous: 定了
Nicous: settled it.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Nicous: 结果她听我跟你说她后来跟我好多好朋友纠缠
Nicous: But she later got entangled with many of my good friends, I'm telling you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina: 我觉得你这人就是也有点惨你知道吧
Katrina: I think you're a bit unlucky, you know?
Nicous: 那些好朋友都是我推的因为我觉得无所屌谓
Nicous: I pushed those good friends away because I didn't care.
Nicous: 就是有的人说
Nicous: It's just that some people say
Katrina: 这正好放一首make friends
Katrina: This is the perfect time to play "make friends."
Nicous: 你能不能推一下
Nicous: Can you push it a bit?
Shure:  乌托邦我想了一首歌
Shure: Utopia, I thought of a song.
Nicous: 然后后来又有一个好朋友说有问题哥们
Nicous: Then later, another good friend said there's a problem, bro.
Katrina:  我初中的时候还在暗恋别人
Katrina: In middle school, I had a secret crush on someone.
Katrina:  暗恋别人
Katrina: A secret crush.
Katrina: 不知道为什么
Katrina: I don't know why.
Katrina:  说就是就是
Katrina: It's just like, you know,
Katrina:  喜欢找人说话
Katrina: I liked talking to people.
Katrina:  因为因为他从来身边没有女生
Katrina: Because he never had girls around him.
Katrina:  然后我在想
Katrina: And I thought,
Katrina:  我喜欢三年不会是
Katrina: Wouldn't it be possible that I liked him for three years, but he's not?
Shure:  都他妈是姐妹
Shure: They're all like sisters.
Katrina:  而且又不会有这种
Katrina: And there's no awkwardness.
Katrina:  刚去成都的时候找我舍友
Katrina: When I first went to Chengdu, I looked for my roommate.
Katrina:  我舍友就带着他们陈启的那个闺蜜哇
Katrina: My roommate took his friend Chen Qi's bestie with him.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Like,
Katrina:  刚好在他们陈启那后面的小吃街里
Katrina: Right in the snack street behind Chen Qi's place.
Katrina:  吃饭他说他说你看嘛
Katrina: When we were eating, he was like, "Look at this."
Katrina:  这也是我们体院比较有名的那
Katrina: This is what our sports school is famous for.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我舔你知道吗
Katrina: Haha, I was licking, you know?
Katrina:  舔了以后就还要还要call back
Katrina: After licking, I had to call back.
Katrina: 我那个舍友
Katrina: My roommate,
Katrina:  就你在图书馆crush
Katrina: You have a crush in the library.
Katrina:  在我们这算算下流货色
Katrina: In our place, it's considered low-class.
Katrina:  哈哈好多帅哥
Katrina: Haha, Chen Qi has so many handsome guys.
Katrina:  嗯感觉太潮了你知道吗就是感觉自己配不上
Katrina: Hmm, it felt too trendy, you know? Like I'm not worthy.
Katrina:  真是太潮了
Katrina: It's just too trendy.
Katrina:  然后一个个一米八
Katrina: And each one is like six feet tall.
Katrina:  然后那种走路
Katrina: And the way they walk,
Katrina:  就是那种体育生走路
Katrina: Like sports students walk.
Shure:  来一杯吗
Shure: Want a drink?
Katrina:  然后那个双开门
Katrina: And then the double doors.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Shure:  这悲伤玩具
Shure: This sad toy.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一个也很不错的乐队
Shure: It's also a pretty good band.
Choiszt:  我不知道他会不会再来
Choiszt: I don't know if he will come again.
Choiszt:  一楼再扫一遍哎
Choiszt: Let's sweep the first floor again.
Nicous: 不是抽这个抽这个
Nicous: Not this one, this one.
Choiszt: 让我来品鉴一下
Choiszt: Let me have a taste.
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure:  我是因为整个圈子都要抽
Shure: I'm doing this because everyone in the circle smokes.
Shure:  我我我没有
Shure: I... I have no choice.
Shure:  没有办法
Shure: I can't help it.
Katrina: 哦那你为啥不喝酒呢
Katrina: Oh, then why don't you drink?
Katrina: 哦会耽误事是吧
Katrina: Oh, it would mess things up, right?
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure: 喝酒是让你快乐
Shure: Drinking is to make you happy.
Nicous:  但是抽烟能让人
Nicous: But smoking can make people...
Nicous:  冷静就我
Nicous: Calm down, just me.
Shure:  你滚吧就我
Shure: You get out, it's just me.
Shure:  别听他的
Shure: Don't listen to him.
Shure:  喝酒就好
Shure: Just drink.
Katrina:  但是喝酒确实
Katrina: But drinking really...
Katrina:  比如说晚上有事
Katrina: Like if you have things to do at night...
Katrina:  让人压力又很大喝酒
Katrina: It makes you stressed out and you drink.
Shure:  非常好的状态
Shure: It's a really good state.
Katrina:  当时你知道
Katrina: At that time, you know...
Katrina:  我刚分手那会
Katrina: When I just broke up...
Katrina:  我室友他们没有offer
Katrina: My roommates didn't have offers.
Katrina:  然后就因为我们室友基本都保研
Katrina: Because most of my roommates were guaranteed postgrad spots.
Katrina:  然后然后就没人说话
Katrina: So no one talked.
Katrina:  没人说话我就他们天天在图书馆
Katrina: No one talked, they were all in the library every day.
Katrina:  我就一个人在宿舍
Katrina: I was alone in the dorm.
Katrina:  卧槽我前男友
Katrina: Damn, my ex...
Katrina:  够抽象我跟你讲
Katrina: It was so abstract, let me tell you.
Katrina:  我前男友当时嗯
Katrina: My ex at that time, hmm...
Katrina:  他你知道
Katrina: He, you know...
Katrina:  我们分手的导火索是一件非常非常小的事
Katrina: The trigger for our breakup was something very, very small.
Katrina:  有的时候会一起看综艺
Katrina: Sometimes we would watch variety shows together.
Katrina: 然后呢 就是开腾讯会议嘛
Katrina: And then, you know, we would have Tencent meetings.
Alice: 有一道
Alice: There was a...
Katrina:  他觉得我不陪他看那个短视频
Katrina: He felt that I didn't watch short videos with him.
Katrina:  因为我觉得我刚看过
Katrina: Because I thought I had just watched it.
Katrina:  我给他推荐
Katrina: I recommended it to him.
Katrina:  他就跟我就是那种撒娇的人
Katrina: He was that kind of person who acted cute with me.
Katrina:  就是不嘛
Katrina: Just no.
Katrina:  我一定要有女朋友看
Katrina: I must have my girlfriend watch it with me.
Katrina:  但是我不吃这一套
Katrina: But I don't buy that.
Katrina:  你知道我也从来不跟我男朋友撒娇
Katrina: You know, I never act cute with my boyfriend.
Shure: 懂了你已经不爱了
Shure: Got it, you weren't in love anymore.
Katrina:  我从来不撒娇
Katrina: I never act cute.
Katrina:  我再次总结
Katrina: Let me summarize again.
Katrina:  就是再怎么喜欢我都不撒娇
Katrina: No matter how much I like someone, I won't act cute.
Katrina:  我撒不出来
Katrina: I can't do it.
Katrina:  我觉得很恶心
Katrina: I find it disgusting.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后然后就这件事其实也没多大人
Katrina: So this thing wasn't a big deal at all.
Katrina:  就晚上稍微说一下就过了
Katrina: We just talked about it briefly at night and it was over.
Katrina:  然后他就一直就那死态度
Katrina: And then he just kept that dead attitude
Katrina:  然后就一直不说话
Katrina: And then he just wouldn't speak
Katrina:  然后到第二天
Katrina: Then the next day
Katrina:  等到第二天下午2点多回去
Katrina: We waited until around 2 PM to go back
Katrina:  而且我们已经是在一起5年了
Katrina: And we've been together for five years already
Katrina:  就是这个相处模式
Katrina: This is how we get along
Katrina:  还是这个样子
Katrina: Still the same
Katrina:  就是冷战
Katrina: It's just a cold war
Katrina:  他没多大点事他都不愿
Katrina: He wouldn't bow down even for the smallest thing
Katrina:  意低头那种
Katrina: Just wouldn't lower his head
Katrina:  然后我我晚上两点没睡着
Katrina: Then I couldn't sleep at 2 AM
Katrina:  我正准备给他发小作文呢
Katrina: I was just about to write him a long message
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就是复盘复盘
Katrina: To reflect on everything
Katrina:  然后呢然后发现突然一下就说
Katrina: Then I suddenly thought, why should I be the one to do it again?
Katrina:  凭什么又是我发
Katrina: Haha, why should I send it first again?
Katrina:  哈哈凭什么又是我先发
Katrina: Haha, why should I be the one to send it first?
Nicous: 因为他从来不低头是吧
Nicous: Because he never lowers his head, right?
Katrina:  基本不低头
Katrina: Basically never
Nicous:  最后前女友给我讲过一个
Nicous: My ex once told me something
Nicous:  讲过一句话嗯
Nicous: Said one thing, hmm
Nicous:  不然这辈子不会向我低头
Nicous: She said she'd never bow down to me in this life
Nicous:  我说你滚
Nicous: I told her to get lost
Katrina:  就是大家有有事好像
Katrina: It's like when something happens
Katrina:  其实我是那种吃软不吃硬的
Katrina: Actually, I'm the type who responds to softness, not hardness
Katrina:  你只要给我稍微给我一个台阶下
Katrina: Just give me a little way out
Katrina:  我就马上我们俩好好沟通了
Katrina: And I'll immediately communicate well with you
Katrina:  就过了我不记仇那种
Katrina: I don't hold grudges
Katrina:  然后但是
Katrina: But then
Katrina:  然后我第二天知道他有早八
Katrina: I knew he had an 8 AM class the next day
Katrina:  但是他一直没有给我发消息
Katrina: But he still didn't message me
Katrina:  就是到下午两两3点
Katrina: Until around 2 or 3 PM
Katrina:  然后我就给他就把我小作文打打回去
Katrina: So I sent him my long message
Katrina:  然后就当时也比较失望
Katrina: And I was pretty disappointed at the time
Katrina:  然后我就提了分手嘛
Katrina: So I suggested we break up
Katrina:  然后然后呢
Katrina: And then
Katrina:  他就说啊
Katrina: He just said, "ah"
Katrina:  他回的特别幼稚你知道吗
Katrina: His response was so childish, you know?
Katrina:  他说什么
Katrina: What did he say?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈永远在等这一句
Katrina: Hahaha, always waiting for this line
Katrina:  我当时这句我觉得特下头
Katrina: At that time, I felt this line was really off-putting.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  你看我给你分析的问题了吗
Katrina: Did you see the problem I analyzed for you?
Katrina:  你就哈哈哈
Katrina: And you just laughed.
Katrina:  他这句话
Katrina: His line,
Katrina:  一下又把这个道德包袱一下甩我身上
Katrina: suddenly dumped this moral burden on me,
Katrina:  说我我总提分手
Katrina: saying that I always talk about breaking up.
Katrina:  我我靠
Katrina: I mean, come on,
Katrina:  我几年没提分手了
Katrina: I haven't mentioned breaking up for years.
Alice: 这个好像有一点
Alice: That does seem a bit...
Katrina:  大一的时候喜欢你
Katrina: When we were freshmen, I liked you.
Katrina:  然后后来
Katrina: And then later,
Katrina:  那我话还没说完呢
Katrina: Wait, I haven't finished talking yet.
Katrina:  我说你看我干嘛
Katrina: I said, why are you looking at me?
Katrina:  然后我就把这发过去
Katrina: Then I sent this message over.
Katrina:  然后就红感叹号了
Katrina: And then it showed a red exclamation mark.
Katrina:  然后红感叹号以后
Katrina: After the red exclamation mark,
Katrina:  然后再说看其他平台吧
Katrina: I checked other platforms,
Katrina:  都是红感叹号
Katrina: and they all had red exclamation marks.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha,
Katrina:  抖音QQ
Katrina: on Douyin, QQ,
Katrina:  然后包括我的b站
Katrina: even on my Bilibili.
Katrina:  然后所有都被拉黑了
Katrina: Everything was blocked.
Nicous:  蓄谋已久
Nicous: Long premeditated.
Katrina:  非常的侮辱人
Katrina: It was really humiliating.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina:  然后我就就觉得无所谓了
Katrina: I just didn't care anymore.
Katrina:  算了算了
Katrina: Whatever.
Katrina:  就这样吧
Katrina: Fine, fine.
Katrina:  然后等他十天后直接给我打个电话说
Katrina: Then ten days later, he called me saying,
Katrina:  他到武汉了
Katrina: he was in Wuhan.
Katrina:  我说就是我
Katrina: I was like, seriously?
Katrina:  那那十天就一直吃不好睡不好啥的
Katrina: Those ten days, I couldn't eat or sleep properly.
Katrina:  就是你明明理性上会觉得
Katrina: Rationally, you know,
Katrina:  你们俩在一起确实比较痛苦
Katrina: you two together are really painful.
Katrina:  就没必要在一起了
Katrina: It's just not necessary.
Katrina:  但是你晚上的时候
Katrina: But at night,
Katrina:  还是会想到以前开心的事情
Katrina: you still think about the happy times.
Katrina:  因为觉得哎
Katrina: And you think, hey,
Katrina:  怎么就5年就走到现在这个地步了
Katrina: how did we get to this point after 5 years?
Katrina:  好歹也是学生时代
Katrina: After all, it was during our school days.
Katrina:  就这样就跟自己走上来
Katrina: And then, we just walked together like this.
Katrina:  然后呢就在前一天刚要复盘完
Katrina: Then, just the day before, we were about to review everything.
Katrina:  就觉得就克服过去了
Katrina: I felt like we had overcome it.
Katrina:  然后他第二天给我打电话说到武汉站
Katrina: Then the next day he called me saying he was at Wuhan Station.
Katrina:  然后到武汉站了以后
Katrina: After he arrived at Wuhan Station,
Katrina:  我就说那天哪见面呢
Katrina: I asked where we should meet that day.
Katrina:  感觉特奇怪你知道吗
Katrina: It felt so weird, you know?
Katrina:  饭也不想跟他吃
Katrina: I didn't even want to have a meal with him.
Katrina:  我就说那你来我们学校吧
Katrina: So I said, why don't you come to our school?
Katrina:  来学校操场走一圈
Katrina: Let's take a walk around the school track.
Katrina:  走一圈看他当时那样子特别惨
Katrina: We walked a lap, and he looked so miserable back then.
Katrina:  就是就是
Katrina: Like, like...
Katrina:  哈哈哈整个人非常颓废你知道吗
Katrina: Hahaha, he was really in a slump, you know?
Katrina:  我说哎呦这个死样子我真服了
Katrina: I was like, oh my gosh, I can't stand this pathetic look.
Katrina:  就是嗯
Katrina: Just, hmm.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Just...
Katrina:  整个人就搞得像那种抑郁症一样
Katrina: He looked like he was depressed.
Katrina:  就是就这样锤的
Katrina: Like beaten down like this.
Katrina:  然后他跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me
Katrina:  他这10天不找我是因为他的胃
Katrina: that he hadn't contacted me for 10 days because of his stomach.
Katrina:  肠胃不舒服
Katrina: His stomach wasn't feeling well.
Katrina:  然后不是有情绪器官吗
Katrina: There's that emotional organ, right?
Katrina:  就情绪不好
Katrina: His emotions were bad.
Katrina:  然后导致肠胃不舒服
Katrina: Which made his stomach upset.
Katrina:  就去校医院一直呃检查来着
Katrina: So he kept going to the school hospital for check-ups.
Katrina:  我说你不会加个微信吗
Katrina: I said, couldn't you just add me on WeChat?
Katrina:  你说但凡想想挽回一点
Katrina: If you wanted to salvage something,
Katrina:  你都可以加个微信说一下
Katrina: you could've added me on WeChat and told me.
Katrina:  哎就我们稍微冷静一下
Katrina: Like, let's cool down a bit.
Katrina:  但是我并不是想真的很分手对吧
Katrina: But I don't really want to break up, right?
Lucia: 我手机快没电了
Lucia: My phone's almost out of battery.
Alice: 这有充电宝
Alice: There's a power bank here.
Lucia: 但没有线
Lucia: But no cable.
Lucia: 又回到了最初的问题
Lucia: Back to the original problem.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 我可以充一下吗谢谢
Lucia: Can I charge it for a bit? Thanks.
Katrina: 所以我们俩就是死锁你知道吗
Katrina: So, we're in a deadlock, you know?
Katrina: 互相等对方的消息
Katrina: Waiting for each other's message.
Katrina: 他那边显示他结尾我这边显示我结尾
Katrina: His side shows he's done, my side shows I'm done.
Shure:  想想我们了吗杨老板
Shure: Miss us, Jake?
Jake:想你们了想你了
Jake: Yeah, I missed you guys, missed you.
Shure:  来来坐坐一会坐一会
Shure: Come on, sit down for a bit, sit for a bit.
Shure:  给杨老板拿拿凳子来
Shure: Get a chair for Jake.
Lucia: 你在看他的火彩吗
Lucia: Are you looking at his opal?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 然后我看他里面有没有什么小气泡啊
Alice: And I'm checking for any small bubbles.
Alice: 小裂缝啥的
Alice: Or tiny cracks or anything.
Alice: 因为我最近摔他有几次
Alice: Because I've dropped it a few times recently.
Alice: 我怕里面有小裂纹
Alice: I'm worried there might be small cracks inside.
Lucia: 这是蛋白石哦
Lucia: This is opal, you know.
Alice: 我发现里面进水了
Alice: I noticed there's water inside.
Shure:  明晚烤串
Shure: BBQ tomorrow night.
Alice: 就是这个托跟这个石头
Alice: It's just that the setting and the stone...
Alice: 里面有一点点水渍
Alice: There's a little bit of water stain inside.
Lucia: 是这个只有这边
Lucia: Is this only on this side?
Lucia: 是你自己设计的还是整个都是你
Lucia: Did you design it yourself or did you do the whole thing?
Alice: 整个
Alice: The whole thing.
Lucia: 啊好好看
Lucia: Ah, it looks so good.
Alice: 我比较喜欢海星
Alice: I really like starfish.
Alice: 上面镶了钻石
Alice: It's set with diamonds.
Alice: 虽然有点小
Alice: Even though they're a bit small.
Alice: 不够闪耀
Alice: Not shiny enough.
Lucia: 好看的
Lucia: It's beautiful.
Alice: 这火彩还挺好的
Alice: The play of color is really good.
Shure:  来走一个
Shure: Let's have a drink.
Shure:  没电了
Shure: Out of battery.
Alice:比较活
Alice: It's quite lively.
Alice:很喜欢
Alice: I really like it.
Lucia: 真的好好看
Lucia: It's really pretty.
Lucia: 我也特别喜欢闪闪发亮的东西
Lucia: I also really like shiny things.
Jake:然后一会讲一下就是房间准备
Jake: Then later we'll talk about room preparation.
Alice: 在说话吗
Alice: Are you talking?
Lucia: 我是不是现在该
Lucia: Should I now...
Lucia: 赶快把我的照片墙买回来
Lucia: Hurry and buy back my photo wall?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:我们一会要讲一下照片怎么不是照片怎么
Lucia: We need to discuss how to, not photos, but...
Lucia: 房间怎么布置
Lucia: How to decorate the room.
Jake: 今天就结束了
Jake: That's it for today.
Jake: 然后明天早上交换礼物
Jake: And then tomorrow morning, we'll exchange gifts.
Jake: 呃然后下午就去他们说的公园是吧
Jake: Uh, and in the afternoon, we go to that park they mentioned, right?
Jake: 你们讨论过吗
Jake: Did you guys discuss it?
Lucia: 我们没讨论出去什么公园
Lucia: We didn't discuss going to any park.
Lucia: 因为不知道附近有什么公园
Lucia: Because we don't know if there's any park nearby.
Alice: 那一波讨论了
Alice: That group discussed it.
Jake: 那你们没有讨论
Jake: So, you didn't discuss it.
Alice: 都可以
Alice: I'm okay with anything.
Lucia: 对我们follow他们的idea
Lucia: Yeah, we'll follow their idea.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake: 那明天就这样
Jake: So, that's the plan for tomorrow.
Jake: 主要是等快递吧
Jake: Mainly waiting for the delivery, right?
Jake: 就是快递周五到大概会吗
Jake: The delivery should arrive around Friday, right?
Jake: 你们如果有快递的话
Jake: If you have any deliveries.
Alice: 我们那个布置是需要落地的吗
Alice: Does our setup need to be on the ground?
Lucia: 需要落地吗
Lucia: Does it need to be on the ground?
Lucia: 要落地
Lucia: Yes, it needs to be on the ground.
Lucia: 对那感觉
Lucia: Yeah, that feeling.
Lucia: 周六快的话周六应该能到
Lucia: If we're quick, it should arrive by Saturday.
Lucia: 周三最快也得明天才能发货嘛对吧
Lucia: The earliest it can ship is tomorrow, right?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 有点呛
Alice: It's a bit tight.
Lucia: 照片墙
Lucia: Photo wall.
Alice:哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh my god.
Lucia: 然后一些小装饰
Lucia: And some small decorations.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 因为我那个房子里面那个架子
Lucia: Because the shelf in my house...
Lucia: 不太好布置
Lucia: It's not easy to decorate.
Lucia: 我想买一个小一点的小桌
Lucia: I want to buy a small table.
Lucia: 然后给他盖一个桌布
Lucia: And cover it with a tablecloth.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 理论上说一般三天应该是可以到的
Lucia: In theory, it should arrive in three days.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 就是如果我们今天晚上确定要落地的
Lucia: So if we decide on the ground setup tonight...
Lucia: 话就
Lucia: Then...
Jake:今晚下单
Jake: Order it tonight.
Jake: 去京东明日达
Jake: Use JD's next-day delivery.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 如果有京东明日达能能到的东西
Lucia: If there's something available for JD next-day delivery.
Lucia: 在京东明日达上买优秀
Lucia: Buy it on JD next-day delivery, it's excellent.
Jake: 明日吧或者星期五到应该都没问题
Jake: Tomorrow or Friday should both be fine.
Lucia: 我看一眼今天的
Lucia: Let me check today's schedule.
Alice: 可以进去了吗
Alice: Can we go in now?
Lucia: 应该可以了吧
Lucia: It should be okay now.
Lucia: 他应该扫完了
Lucia: He should have finished scanning.
Katrina:  发短信
Katrina: Send a text.
Katrina:  他考本校吧
Katrina: He's applying to this school, right?
Katrina:  他本来是同济大学啊
Katrina: He was originally at Tongji University.
Katrina:  还有就是
Katrina: And also...
Katrina:  我觉得我跟他未来规划完全不一样
Katrina: I feel our future plans are completely different.
Katrina:  因为他当时他考研择校比我早嘛
Katrina: Because he chose his grad school way earlier than me.
Katrina:  就是关于就是我们俩这个分支问题
Katrina: It’s about the direction we're taking.
Katrina:  我们本来还是想大家往一个地方跑
Katrina: We originally wanted to head to the same place.
Katrina:  就一个地域吧
Katrina: Like the same region.
Katrina:  中部东部什么的
Katrina: Central or eastern areas, whatever.
Shure:  那你们是考虑的很很远一些是吗
Shure: So you guys are thinking long-term, huh?
Katrina:  我已经就是
Katrina: I mean, back then...
Katrina:  我觉得当时觉得没什么
Katrina: I thought it wasn't a big deal.
Katrina:  我谈恋爱就是没什么问题就能相处啊
Katrina: I thought dating wouldn’t be an issue, we could get along.
Katrina:  就能继续下去啊
Katrina: We could keep going.
Katrina:  然后他
Katrina: And then he...
Katrina:  他就没什么规划的包括他考研的
Katrina: He didn't have any plans, including his grad school exams.
Katrina:  包括他考研择校还还是我问他
Katrina: Even for choosing a school for grad school, I had to ask him.
Katrina:  我说你打算考哪个
Katrina: I asked him which one he planned to take.
Katrina:  就说我们俩尽量往一个地方就
Katrina: I suggested that we try to aim for the same place.
Katrina:  我可能更希望男生会有担当一点
Katrina: I hoped he would be a bit more responsible.
Katrina:  就去计划一些这些事
Katrina: To plan out some of these things.
Katrina:  可能他是p人吧
Katrina: Maybe he's a P type person.
Katrina:  我当时没有研究MBTI啊这种东西
Katrina: I didn't know about MBTI and all that back then.
Katrina:  你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  然后我就希望
Katrina: So I hoped...
Katrina:  我们俩就是有一个明确的规划
Katrina: We could have a clear plan.
Katrina:  要不然就异地遥遥无期啊
Katrina: Otherwise, long-distance would be endless.
Katrina:  看研究生跟我就越隔越远
Katrina: I'd see him getting further away during grad school.
Katrina:  武汉到重庆变成南京到重庆
Katrina: From Wuhan to Chongqing, then Nanjing to Chongqing.
Katrina:  然后他可能要他
Katrina: And then maybe he...
Katrina:  他学材料
Katrina: He studies materials.
Katrina:  材料在中部的国企比较多
Katrina: There are more state-owned enterprises in central China.
Katrina:  他要留那我留我可能去杭州那边
Katrina: He wants to stay, and I might go to Hangzhou.
Katrina:  然后那就就就遥遥无期你知道吧
Katrina: Then it would just be endless, you know?
Katrina:  而且他也没有给我一个那种比较
Katrina: And he didn't give me any decent plan.
Katrina:  稍微有像样子的规划
Katrina: Just some vague outline.
Jake:还有还有多少电这个
Jake: How much battery is left?
Tasha: 呃多着呢充着呢
Tasha: Oh, plenty, it's charging.
Lucia: 加一嗯
Lucia: Add one, yeah.
Shure:  废话
Shure: Nonsense.
Katrina:  超爽
Katrina: Super cool.
Katrina:  早分早分
Katrina: Early split, early split.
Katrina:  哈哈当时也有人问我要微信啊
Katrina: Haha, someone even asked for my WeChat at that time.
Shure:  当时有人跟我要微信啊
Shure: Someone asked for my WeChat too.
Nicous:  有有对象的时候也可以加微信
Nicous: You can add WeChat even if you have a partner.
Shure:  咦谢冰竹你干什么
Shure: Eh, Xie Bingzhu, what are you doing?
Katrina:  大一的时候因为我自己也跟男生
Katrina: During my freshman year, I hung out with guys.
Katrina:  就是我性格比较像男生
Katrina: I have a boyish personality.
Katrina:  我就高中也跟男生玩的比较多嘛
Katrina: In high school, I mostly hung out with guys.
Katrina:  所以我不管他异性朋友
Katrina: So, I didn't mind his female friends.
Katrina:  然后我就比较相信他那种
Katrina: I trusted him.
Katrina:  然后大一的时候
Katrina: Then in my freshman year,
Katrina:  那女生就是他所谓的女闺蜜
Katrina: this girl, supposedly his bestie,
Katrina:  就在他女在东华大学
Katrina: she was at Donghua University.
Katrina:  然后就社团喝醉酒了
Katrina: She got drunk at a club.
Katrina:  就给他半夜打电话
Katrina: And called him in the middle of the night.
Katrina:  然后他早上还问人家
Katrina: And he even asked her in the morning
Katrina:  有没有安全到学校
Katrina: if she got back to campus safely.
Lucia: 你的灯灭了哈哈哈
Lucia: Your light went out, haha.
Jake:嗯是我也没电了
Jake: Yeah, I'm out of battery too.
Shure:  半夜打电话
Shure: Calling in the middle of the night.
Nicous:  三个人相处很好
Nicous: The three of us got along well.
Shure:  只是半夜打电话而已
Shure: It was just a midnight call.
Shure:  没有半夜半夜半夜睡
Shure: No big deal, just a midnight call.
Shure:  睡到一起已经不错了你知道吧
Shure: It's already good enough they didn't sleep together, you know?
Katrina:  然后然后
Katrina: Then, then...
Alice: 今天结束了吗
Alice: Is it over for today?
Jake: 没有对着每个房间讲
Jake: No, we still need to talk to each room.
Jake: 吹吹牛逼就结束了
Jake: Just chat a bit, then we're done.
Alice: 什么时候开始
Alice: When does it start?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Right now.
Jake:等我等我有电
Jake: Wait for me to get some power.
Lucia: 啊他要冲到10%以上才能开机
Lucia: Ah, it needs to charge above 10% to turn on.
Lucia: 就是我们现在要打一下草稿是吗
Lucia: So, we need to draft it first, right?
Lucia: 吹牛皮也要打一下草稿
Lucia: Even for bragging, you need a draft.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 没什么草稿
Lucia: There's no draft.
Lucia: 我可以申请拥有一只章鱼吗
Lucia: Can I apply to own an octopus?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 申请什么有什么章鱼
Jake: Apply for what? What octopus?
Lucia: 把它当成一个装饰
Lucia: As a decoration.
Alice: 这快递地址能发在群里吗
Alice: Can we post this delivery address in the group?
Lucia: 不是活的
Lucia: It's not alive.
Lucia: 是那个毛绒玩具了
Lucia: It's a plush toy.
Katrina:  然后那次那那次就分手
Katrina: And then we broke up that time.
Katrina:  然后不知道自己哄回来了
Katrina: Then I somehow got him back.
Katrina:  哄回来给我买两支香奈儿口红还买错了
Katrina: He bought me two Chanel lipsticks to make up, but he got the wrong ones.
Katrina: 买没错了
Katrina: Well, not really wrong.
Lucia: 我还在想我需要什么其他的蓝色装饰
Lucia: I'm still thinking about what other blue decorations I need.
Lucia: 让他看起来更
Lucia: To make it look more...
Alice:欧根纱
Alice: Organza.
Lucia: 蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Blue organza.
Alice: 嗯一种很梦幻的材料
Alice: Yeah, it's a very dreamy material.
Lucia: 我大概知道它什么样
Lucia: I think I know what it looks like.
Lucia: 有裙子用那个材料做的
Lucia: There are dresses made from that material.
Lucia: 会很蓬
Lucia: It will be very puffy.
Alice: 流光溢彩
Alice: Shiny and colorful.
Katrina: 他干事很不踏实你知道吧
Katrina: He's really unreliable, you know.
Katrina: 很不用心呐那稍微看一下
Katrina: He doesn't put his heart into it, just a little bit of effort.
Katrina: 你看你连个中文日文都要比对一下对吧
Katrina: Look, you even have to compare Chinese and Japanese characters, right?
Katrina:  我靠我从来没骂过人
Katrina: Damn, I've never cursed at anyone.
Katrina: 包括他给我拍照哦前男友
Katrina: Even when he took ugly photos of me, my ex.
Katrina: 拍照特别丑的时候我都没骂过
Katrina: When the photos were really bad, I never cursed.
Katrina:  因为我当时是这样想的
Katrina: Because I thought like this.
Katrina:  人家给你拍照也有苦就是
Katrina: He has his struggles taking photos for you.
Nicous:  没有功劳也有苦
Nicous: No credit, but still hard work.
Katrina:  嗯嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  我不会去骂人家对不对
Katrina: I wouldn't curse at him, right?
Katrina:  哎我觉得可p可p
Katrina: I thought it could be edited, or...
Katrina:  或者就是哎
Katrina: Or just...
Katrina:  没事大不了就不发这朋友圈啊
Katrina: Never mind, just don't post it on social media.
Katrina:  太懂事了
Katrina: So considerate.
Katrina:  谁他妈跟我谈
Katrina: Whoever dates me.
Katrina:  真是有福了
Katrina: Is really lucky.
Katrina:  从来没有骂过他
Katrina: I've never yelled at him.
Katrina:  然后包括我分手以后
Katrina: Even after we broke up,
Katrina:  我看我室友他们谈恋爱
Katrina: I saw my roommates dating.
Katrina:  他们是直接就可能说话就比较直
Katrina: They speak pretty bluntly.
Katrina:  他们说哎你这样太邋遢太丑了
Katrina: They say things like "you're too sloppy and ugly."
Katrina:  我靠从来没有说过带脏字的哎
Katrina: Damn, I've never said a single curse word.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Katrina: 哦我当时觉得
Katrina: Oh, at that time I thought...
Katrina: 最搞笑的是不会
Katrina: The funniest thing is we never...
Katrina: 我们俩吵架也不会骂人
Katrina: Even when we argued, we never cursed.
Lucia: 小时达
Lucia: Xiaoshida.
Alice: 你竟然有网
Alice: You actually have internet.
Lucia: 嗯有网
Lucia: Yeah, there's internet.
Alice:我去
Alice: Wow.
Katrina: 他脑回路跟正常人不太一样我总感觉
Katrina: I always feel like his thought process is different from normal people.
Lucia: 咱们这是张家湾吗
Lucia: Are we in Zhangjiawan?
Lucia: 这什么地方
Lucia: Where is this place?
Lucia: 他怎么给我自动定位到
Lucia: How did it auto-locate me here?
Lucia: 张
Lucia: Zhang...
Lucia: 家湾
Lucia: ...jiawan.
Lucia: 啊还真在这附近啊let me check
Lucia: Ah, it really is nearby. Let me check.
Lucia: 照片墙照片打印机
Lucia: Photo wall, photo printer.
Lucia: 这个也很有用
Lucia: This is also very useful.
Alice: 困了困了
Alice: I'm so sleepy.
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Same here.
Alice: 现在能先卸妆吗
Alice: Can I take off my makeup now?
Lucia: 可能应该也可以吧
Lucia: Maybe you can.
Alice:开始把眼镜去了
Alice: I'll start by taking off my glasses.
Lucia: 啊小心等一次这个还连着呢
Lucia: Ah, careful, it's still connected.
Lucia: 嗯咱俩要不要换一下充电宝
Lucia: Hmm, should we swap power banks?
Lucia: 你需要充手机吗
Lucia: Do you need to charge your phone?
Alice: 嗯不需要
Alice: No, I don't.
Lucia: 那可以换一下吗因为我怕我这个
Lucia: Can we switch then? I'm afraid mine...
Lucia: 手机一会没电了
Lucia: My phone might run out of battery soon.
Lucia: 这个给你
Lucia: Here, take this one.
Lucia: 诶又到这首歌了
Lucia: Hey, it's this song again.
Lucia: 觉得这个派他应该还好着吧
Lucia: Do you think this pie is still good?
Lucia: 我有点想把它吃了
Lucia: I'm kind of tempted to eat it.
Alice: 你打一下
Alice: Give it a try.
Lucia: 其实我也不饿
Lucia: Actually, I'm not even hungry.
Lucia: 但我就是有点想吃
Lucia: But I kind of want to eat it.
Alice: 你用微波炉热它一下吧
Alice: Just heat it up in the microwave.
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, right.
Lucia: 我用微波炉热一下
Lucia: I'll heat it in the microwave.
Lucia: 看一眼它没坏吧
Lucia: Check if it's spoiled.
Lucia: 这么短时间应该不会长毛对吧
Lucia: It shouldn't go bad in such a short time, right?
Alice: 没它是有盐有糖的
Alice: No, it's got salt and sugar in it.
Lucia: 嗯那我就热一下
Lucia: Okay, I'll heat it up then.
Lucia: 上面是微波炉
Lucia: The microwave's on top.
Lucia: 底下是烤箱
Lucia: The oven's below.
Lucia: 纸能直接放
Lucia: Can I put the paper in directly?
Lucia: 算了我那个啥吧
Lucia: Never mind, I'll just...
Lucia: 我决定给他找个盘子
Lucia: I'll find a plate for it.
Lucia: 诶我们的纸
Lucia: Hey, our paper.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Jake:来吧
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:开吹吧
Jake: Let's start.
Alice: 就我们仨
Alice: Just the three of us.
Jake: 都来了
Jake: Everyone's here.
Jake: 别门得关了
Jake: Close the door.
Jake: 进来吧进来吧
Jake: Come in, come in.
Jake: 哎开开了
Jake: Oh, it's open.
Choiszt:  今天晚上GoPro还导吗
Choiszt: Are we transferring the GoPro footage tonight?
Jake: 导
Jake: Yes.
Choiszt:  十分钟五分钟
Choiszt: Ten minutes, five minutes?
Jake: 希望如此吧
Jake: Hopefully.
Jake: 这不要立flag
Jake: Let's not jinx it.
Jake: 真的
Jake: Seriously.
Jake: 我靠行行
Jake: Oh my gosh, alright.
Choiszt: 让你美梦成真一下
Choiszt: May your dream come true.
Jake: 我靠这真的真的
Jake: Oh my gosh, really, really.
Jake: 做梦时候就在想这个
Jake: I dream about this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 主要是插电不方便
Jake: The main issue is plugging it in is inconvenient.
Lucia: 啊我突然有点想把那个派吃了哦
Lucia: 决定来点夜宵
Lucia: Decided to have a midnight snack.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 不光想来点夜宵甚至还想看看有别的什么能吃的
Lucia: Not only do I want a midnight snack, I also want to see if there's anything else to eat.
Lucia: 我把这个录一个
Lucia: I'll record this.
Jake: 不是你那拍照不给我录啥意思
Jake: Why can't you record while taking photos?
Jake: 对就聊聊就吹吹牛就拉倒
Jake: Yeah, just chat, brag a bit, and that's it.
Jake: 啊不交换礼物
Jake: Oh, no gift exchange.
Jake: 明早交换礼物
Jake: We'll exchange gifts tomorrow morning.
Jake: 什么派
Jake: What pie?
Lucia: 我还没吃
Lucia: I haven't eaten it yet.
Lucia: 我尝一口告诉你哦
Lucia: Let me try it and I'll tell you.
Jake: 你还不知道什么派
Jake: You don't know what pie it is?
Lucia: 嗯薛定鄂的派
Lucia: Hmm, Schrödinger's pie.
Katrina:  显示电量太低
Katrina: The battery is too low.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 你给他充一会
Jake: Charge it for a while.
Jake: 你也没电了
Jake: You're out of battery too.
Jake: 你没电了呀
Jake: You're out of battery.
Jake: 你没电了
Jake: 你连不上看不了
Jake: You can't connect or watch anything.
Lucia: no that's mine
Lucia: No, that's mine.
Lucia: 哈哈当然你可以用
Lucia: Haha, of course you can use it.
Katrina:  这个味道变了吗
Katrina: Has the taste changed?
Katrina: 放两天了
Katrina: It's been two days.
Lucia: 没有昨天的吧这是一天
Lucia: No, it's from yesterday, just one day.
Lucia: 这么甜应该不容易坏
Lucia: It's so sweet, it shouldn't spoil easily.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  西柚就是比橙汁兑着好
Katrina: Grapefruit juice is better than orange juice.
Lucia: 橙汁适合加入那个龙舌兰
Lucia: Orange juice is good with tequila.
Lucia: 好这个薛定谔的派是红豆味的
Lucia: Okay, this Schrödinger's pie is red bean flavored.
Jake: 红豆味哈哈红豆
Jake: Red bean flavor, haha, red bean.
Lucia: 小心没事
Lucia: Be careful, it's fine.
Jake: 他得冲到5%左右吧
Jake: It needs to charge to about 5%.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Katrina: 10%才可以
Katrina: 10% should be enough.
Katrina: 讲是不是自己带着自己说一下就行
Katrina: Just talk about it yourself, that's enough.
Katrina: 讲你的设计理念
Katrina: Share your design concept.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 其实是一伙人进去围观
Jake: It's actually a group of people watching.
Shure: 一伙人来我房间睡吗
Shure: A group of people coming to sleep in my room?
Lucia:  no thank you
Lucia: No, thank you.
Katrina: 我迟早把你这录下来
Katrina: I'll record this sooner or later.
Lucia: 啊我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: Ah, my glasses are on.
Jake: 哈哈哈执法执法记录仪
Jake: Hahaha, law enforcement body cam.
Lucia: 执法记录仪
Lucia: Law enforcement recorder.
Lucia: 我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: My glasses are on.
Lucia: 谨言慎行啊哈哈
Lucia: Be cautious, haha.
Shure:  好有经验好有经验什么鬼
Shure: So experienced, so experienced. What the heck?
Katrina:  这到底是什么呀
Katrina: What the heck is this?
Nicous:  按的按
Nicous: Press it, press.
Nicous:  就是是一和7
Nicous: It's 1 and 7.
Jake: 这是什么呃
Jake: What's this, um...
Nicous:  这是什么
Nicous: What's this?
Nicous:  那这个一和7的
Nicous: This 1 and 7 here.
Nicous:  嗯这就是一个
Nicous: Hmm, this is just one...
Lucia: 嗯这是地球吗
Lucia: Hmm, is this Earth?
Lucia: 有点像是吧
Lucia: Looks like it, right?
Jake: 这是什么方向呢
Jake: Which direction is this?
Jake: 澳大利亚
Jake: Australia?
Jake: 南极
Jake: Antarctica?
Lucia: 这可以是澳大利亚
Lucia: This could be Australia.
Lucia: 这可以是新西兰
Lucia: This could be New Zealand.
Lucia: 虽然比例有点不对
Lucia: Though the scale is a bit off.
Lucia: 但他可以
Lucia: But it could be.
Katrina: 北京看音乐节是不得往通州这跑啊
Katrina: To watch a music festival in Beijing, you have to go to Tongzhou, right?
Shure: 草莓音乐节嘛
Shure: Strawberry Music Festival, right?
Shure: 好多好多认识的朋友
Shure: Lots and lots of friends I know.
Nicous:  卧槽
Nicous: Damn.
Shure: 从北京走到北京三个小时
Shure: Walking from Beijing to Beijing takes three hours.
Nicous: 我这不明天就肺癌
Nicous: I'll get lung cancer by tomorrow.
Nicous:  你是人吗
Nicous: Are you even human?
Jake: 你直接吃了吧
Jake: Just eat it directly.
Nicous: 我靠我他妈吃了都比抽健康
Nicous: Damn, eating it is healthier than smoking it.
Nicous:  就是减少
Nicous: Just cut down.
Nicous:  我说你这也太抽象了拍我
Nicous: I mean, this is too abstract. Take a picture of me.
Choiszt:  我以为是因为我看那个什么电视
Choiszt: I thought it was because I was watching some show.
Katrina:  对方很能很容易看到我的情绪
Katrina: The other party can easily see my emotions.
Katrina: 因为我正常来说话都可以给人发十几条那种
Katrina: Because normally, I can send dozens of messages while talking.
Katrina: 他不回我都无所谓
Katrina: It doesn't matter if they don't reply.
Katrina: 但是呢我只要那只要那发一条
Katrina: But if I send just one message,
Katrina: 那消息这明显就是生气啊
Katrina: it's obvious that I'm angry.
Katrina: 就是说明显能看出来但是还是不愿意来
Katrina: It means it's clearly visible, but they still don't want to come.
Jake: 你在这秀
Jake: You're showing off here.
Jake: 哈哈不给看
Jake: Haha, not letting us see.
Shure:  哎呀啊啊
Shure: Ahhhh!
Katrina:  好恶心啊
Katrina: That's so disgusting.
Nicous: 给你带来了快乐你开着呢
Nicous: It brought you joy, didn't it?
Katrina: 我从来没见过一个南京人口音能那么重
Katrina: I've never heard a Nanjing accent that strong.
Katrina: 我身边的南京人我去南京那么多趟
Katrina: The Nanjing people around me, and I've been to Nanjing so many times.
Nicous:  你觉得我们俩口音像吗
Nicous: Do you think our accents sound alike?
Jake: 不像
Jake: Not really.
Nicous: 但是但是我我那些同学听到我
Nicous: But, but my classmates, when they hear me...
:Jake:我知道我知道哈哈
Jake: I know, I know, haha.
Katrina: 但是我觉得你口音特别像安徽人
Katrina: But I think your accent sounds a lot like Anhui.
Nicous: 我就是安徽的
Nicous: I am from Anhui.
Nicous: 我马鞍山马鞍山的
Nicous: I'm from Ma'anshan, Ma'anshan.
Jake: 哎你也没电了
Jake: Hey, you're out of battery too.
Tasha: 我刚充上电了已经
Tasha: I just charged it already.
Jake: 好吧我们走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 我感觉凑不了凑不到人
Jake: I feel like we can't gather enough people.
Jake: 喝多了
Jake: Drank too much.
Jake: 意思一下
Jake: Just for the sake of it.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 哎这现在还不能拔是吧
Lucia: Hey, you can't unplug it yet, right?
Lucia: 那我把
Lucia: Then I'll...
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Lucia: 那根线上还写着我名字呢
Lucia: The wire even has my name on it.
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Lucia: 好吧原来您也看过魔剑
Lucia: Alright, so you’ve watched "The Magic Sword" too.
Lucia: 我还害怕
Lucia: I was worried.
Lucia: 我今天讲那个关于咕噜的冷笑话
Lucia: I told that joke about Gollum today.
Lucia: 没人听懂来着
Lucia: No one got it.
Katrina:  来吧来吧
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Jake:来吧
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  先先先介绍什么
Shure: What should we introduce first?
Jake: 你开了吗你
Jake: Did you start it?
Katrina:  没开
Katrina: No, I didn't.
Jake: 先先聊到可心啊
Jake: Let's talk about something interesting first.
Alice: 都要进来吗
Alice: Is everyone coming in?
Jake: 对毕竟你收拾过了吧
Jake: Yeah, after all, you cleaned up, right?
Alice: 啊我的想法就是
Alice: Ah, my thought is...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 因为这个房间比较小
Alice: Because this room is small.
Alice: 然后这个白色占的面积特别大
Alice: And the white color takes up a lot of space.
Alice: 我就打算买一个床单
Alice: I'm planning to buy a bedsheet.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 然后就整体上就看起来被改造过了
Alice: Then the whole look will seem transformed.
Alice: 然后搞一个桌布
Alice: And then get a tablecloth.
Alice: 然后这个上面放一个微型的小的
Alice: Then put a tiny little...
Alice: 小的景观
Alice: Small landscape.
Alice: 微型景观
Alice: Mini landscape.
Alice: 然后有海藻球
Alice: And then some marimo moss balls.
Alice: 然后买一个杯垫
Alice: Then buy a coaster.
Alice: 然后上面放一个桂花味的香薰
Alice: And put an osmanthus scented candle on it.
Alice: 整体就是一个跟这个米黄色搭相近的
Alice: The overall look is close to this beige color.
Alice: 一个奶绿色吧左右的
Alice: Like a light greenish color.
Alice: 大概就是这样
Alice: Something like that.
Jake: 这叫啥主题呢
Jake: What's the theme called?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Alice: 初春主题
Alice: Early Spring theme.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: make sense
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 好make sense
Jake: Yeah, makes sense.
Alice: OK了啊就这样
Alice: Okay, that's it.
Jake: 来看你怎么吹牛逼
Jake: Let's see how you're bragging.
Jake: 还不能吹你的是吧那我
Jake: Can't even brag about yours, huh, then I...
Shure: 我还太漏了
Shure: I'm still too exposed.
Jake: 好那我们先上楼吧
Jake: Alright, let's go upstairs first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 就赛博主题
Jake: Cyber theme.
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经装修好了
Lucia: Haha, it's already decorated.
Jake: 完工完工状态
Jake: Finished, finished status.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Lucia: 进度100%
Lucia: Progress 100%.
Jake: 还是蓝色
Jake: Still blue.
Jake: 地球地球赛博
Jake: Earth, Earth cyber.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 蓝白相间
Lucia: Blue and white.
Jake: 对停电一小时电脑都开着
Jake: Yeah, power outage for an hour, but the computer's still on.
Lucia: 哦对这是科幻主题吧
Lucia: Oh right, this is a sci-fi theme, right?
Katrina: 三个钩子我就是
Katrina: Three hooks, I mean.
Jake:挂三个钩子
Jake: Hang three hooks.
Katrina: 三幅那个叫什么卷帘画
Katrina: Three of those roller blinds, what are they called?
Katrina: 我的主题叫动物party
Katrina: My theme is called Animal Party.
Jake: 叫什么动物派对
Jake: What's the name again, Animal Party?
Katrina: 动物派对
Katrina: Animal Party.
Jake: 动物派对动物partyOK
Jake: Animal Party, Animal Party, OK.
Katrina:  这边全都是那种画就是那种偏春天
Katrina: Over here, the paintings are all kind of spring-themed.
Katrina:  然后动物的
Katrina: And animal-themed.
Katrina:  然后这边也搞一个那个画
Katrina: Then over here, we'll also put up a painting.
Katrina:  就是买那个美纹纸贴一个大的那个
Katrina: We'll use washi tape to put up a big poster-like thing.
Katrina:  呃海报一样的
Katrina: Like a wall poster.
Katrina:  然后这边挂一个那个壁画
Katrina: Then we'll hang a mural here.
Katrina:  然后这边摆几个小娃娃
Katrina: And place some little dolls here.
Katrina:  就是全部是动物的那种
Katrina: Everything will be animal-themed.
Katrina:  然后地上搞一个那个地毯
Katrina: Then we'll put a carpet on the floor.
Katrina:  就是那种苔藓的那种形状的
Katrina: A carpet that looks like moss.
Katrina:  然后那那那边还有一部分的区域
Katrina: And over there, there's another area.
Katrina:  打算就放我的那个花
Katrina: I plan to put my flowers there.
Katrina:  然后还有一个那个香薰小夜灯
Katrina: And also a small aroma diffuser night light.
Katrina:  就是那香薰既能香
Katrina: The diffuser gives off a nice scent.
Katrina:  又有那个夜灯的功能
Katrina: And it also functions as a night light.
Katrina:  然后床上放一个松
Katrina: Then on the bed, we'll put a pine tree...
Katrina:  嗯那个松树的叫什么松树
Katrina: Um, a pine tree... haha, a pine tree plush.
Katrina:  哈哈松树的那个玩偶
Katrina: A pillow, and then a little fox plush.
Katrina:  抱枕然后再放一只小狐狸的那个玩偶
Katrina: And that's pretty much it.
Katrina:  然后差不多就是这样
Katrina: Yeah, everything will have animal elements.
Katrina:  对就是全部都是动物的元素
Katrina: And the overall theme will be green.
Katrina:  然后就是整体是绿色的基调
Katrina: And I've bought everything already.
Katrina:  然后都买好了
Katrina: So it's all set.
Jake: 哦挺好嗯差不多5,000块钱
Jake: Oh, that's nice. About 5,000 yuan, right?
Jake: 好挺好哈哈哈没有没有没有
Jake: Alright, that's good. Haha, no, no, no.
Katrina: 没事我可以自己加点
Katrina: It's fine, I can add a bit more myself.
Katrina:  因为反正我要换到我新家去
Katrina: Since I'll be moving to my new place anyway.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 我我我我也很喜欢这个房间
Jake: I, I, I also really like this room.
Jake: 因为这是我房间原来的样子
Jake: Because this is how my room used to look.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Jake: 现在变成了那个样子
Jake: Now it looks like that.
Tasha: 房间我想要做成一个色彩
Tasha: For my room, I want it to have a colorful, dopamine vibe.
Tasha: 多巴胺的那种感觉
Tasha: Yeah, and I decided to use more blue.
Tasha: 嗯然后我决定再多用一些蓝色
Tasha: Um, and some pink elements too.
Jake: 你还在充电是吧
Jake: Are you still charging?
Tasha: 蓝色和粉色的元素
Tasha: Blue and pink elements.
Tasha: 嗯嗯弄个地毯
Tasha: Hmm, let's get a carpet.
Tasha: 换个床单
Tasha: Change the bedsheet.
Tasha: 再搞一点装饰画
Tasha: Add some decorative paintings.
Tasha: 然后那个窗户
Tasha: And for that window.
Tasha: 我想把它那个贴那种
Tasha: I want to put some kind of...
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Like...
Tasha: 相当于是打开窗户的一个景色的那种
Tasha: Basically, it's like a scenery when you open the window.
Tasha: 窗布嗯嗯
Tasha: Window curtains, yeah.
Lucia: 这样子他就会有那种夏天的感觉
Lucia: That way, it will feel like summer.
Jake: 叫什么来着
Jake: What's it called again?
Katrina:  你的主题
Katrina: Your theme.
Lucia: 多巴胺
Lucia: Dopamine.
Jake:多巴胺
Jake: Dopamine.
Lucia: 是这个主题吗
Lucia: Is that the theme?
Lucia: 我记得对吧
Lucia: I remember, right?
Jake: 到路亚了
Jake: It's up to Lure.
Lucia: 哎呀我这个牛的草稿还没有打好
Lucia: Oh no, I haven't finished drafting this cow yet.
Lucia: 大家就凑合着听一听
Lucia: Everyone just bear with me and listen.
Lucia: 就是我这个房间
Lucia: So, this room of mine.
Lucia: 他很不巧就没有挂钩
Lucia: Unfortunately, it doesn't have hooks.
Lucia: 然后这个桌子
Lucia: And this table.
Jake:你后面其实有个挂钩
Jake: Actually, there's a hook behind you.
Jake: 但是啥也不是
Jake: But it's useless.
Lucia: 哦那个后面啊
Lucia: Oh, behind there?
Lucia: 其实大家也看不到了
Lucia: Actually, no one can see it.
Lucia: 就是姑且认为是他没有吧
Lucia: So let's just say it's not there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 所以我的想法是
Lucia: So my idea is.
Lucia: 我可能把这个搬出去
Lucia: I might move this out.
Lucia: 然后在这里放一个小桌子
Lucia: Then put a small table here.
Lucia: 然后可以给上面盖一个桌布
Lucia: And cover it with a tablecloth.
Lucia: 然后我现在想的大概是蓝白这种主题
Lucia: Now I'm thinking of a blue and white theme.
Lucia: 色调就是搞一个偏地中海这种风格
Lucia: The color scheme is kind of Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 或者说面朝大海
Lucia: Or like facing the sea.
Lucia: 春暖花开这样
Lucia: Spring blossoms.
Lucia: 对然后这边的话
Lucia: Yeah, and over here.
Lucia: 到时候可能还要
Lucia: Maybe also.
Lucia: 我明天还要再看一下格局
Lucia: I'll check the layout tomorrow.
Lucia: 如果合适可能想放一个照片墙
Lucia: If it fits, I might want to put a photo wall.
Lucia: 然后给上面挂一些渔网啊
Lucia: And hang some fishing nets on it.
Lucia: 或者贝壳这样的东西
Lucia: Or something like shells
Lucia: 然后也可以装饰一些照片
Lucia: And you can also decorate with some photos
Lucia: 或者小的那种照贴画
Lucia: Or small sticker pictures
Lucia: 明信片
Lucia: Postcards
Lucia: 嗯然后床单的话
Lucia: Hmm, and about the bed sheets
Lucia: 就是因为这个床
Lucia: It's because this bed
Lucia: 他占的面积实在是很大
Lucia: It takes up a lot of space
Lucia: 所以呃
Lucia: So, uh
Lucia: 我还在想是买一个就是蓝色的
Lucia: I'm still thinking about getting a blue one
Lucia: 就是他的色调和明度
Lucia: Its tone and brightness
Lucia: 这些都跟房间还比较符合的床单呢
Lucia: Would match the room better
Lucia: 还是买两个就是小抱枕
Lucia: Or maybe get two small pillows
Lucia: 比如像鲨鱼啊或者这类的这种海洋生物
Lucia: Like with sharks or other marine animals
Lucia: 嗯然后就没有什么了
Lucia: Hmm, and then that's it
Lucia: 这个窗帘的颜色感觉没有办法改变
Lucia: The color of the curtains can't be changed
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 是窗户很大
Lucia: The window is very big
Lucia: 窗户外面打开的话就就是对面的房子
Lucia: When you open the window, you just see the building opposite
Lucia: 对然后我还有一个想法是
Lucia: Yeah, and I have another idea
Lucia: 可能会买一个小夜灯然后就是
Lucia: Maybe get a small night light
Lucia: 如果说把灯关上然后打开他的话
Lucia: If you turn off the main light and turn it on
Lucia: 就能有一种波光粼粼的效果
Lucia: It would create a shimmering effect
Katrina: 像投影仪
Katrina: Like a projector
Lucia: 对对对是的就很符合大海这个主题
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly, it matches the ocean theme
Lucia: 对谢谢大家希望顺利
Lucia: Yeah, thank you everyone, hope it goes well
Shure: 我一直显示0%
Shure: It's still showing 0%
Jake:你充上了吗
Jake: Did you plug it in?
Shure: 我确实是充着呢
Shure: Yeah, I definitely plugged it in
Jake:刚刚扫的时候
Jake: When I scanned earlier
Jake:就觉得你这个地方素材挺多
Jake: I noticed you have a lot of materials here
Shure: welcome
Shure: Welcome
Katrina: 你把花也买下来
Katrina: Did you buy the flowers too?
Jake:你剪过吗
Jake: Did you trim them?
Jake:这个花
Jake: These flowers
Shure: 没有我觉得它本来的样子就是最完美的
Shure: No, I think they look perfect as they are
Shure: 就是雨轩同学插上的样子
Shure: Just the way Yuxuan arranged them
Shure: 就是very perfect
Shure: It's very perfect
Katrina: 原生态
Katrina: Natural style
Katrina: 他这自带这种东西
Katrina: He always has this kind of thing
Lucia: 好好啊
Lucia: That's great
Katrina: 那他买点那个东西装摆上面就好了
Katrina: He can just buy some stuff to put on top.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 加一点小装饰
Lucia: Add a little decoration.
Shure: 我也我也不知道要买些什么
Shure: I also don't know what to buy.
Shure: 就是哎我我我杂物就堆在这里了
Shure: I just pile my stuff here.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
Shure: 因为需要充电的设备
Shure: Because the devices need to be charged.
Shure: 每天就就在这啪插着
Shure: I just plug them in here every day.
Shure: 然后然后充在这里然后
Shure: And then charge them here.
Jake:代表什么呀
Jake: What does that signify?
Katrina: 赛博人生续命
Katrina: Cyber life extension.
Shure: 人生需要一些
Shure: Life needs some...
Katrina: charge
Katrina: Charge.
Shure: charge耶雨轩说同学说的很好
Shure: Charge, yeah, Yu Xuan said it well.
Katrina: 特别像老师讲课
Katrina: Sounds just like a teacher.
Shure: 这个这个就床
Shure: This, this is just a bed.
Shure: 就是他就他就是个床
Shure: It's just a bed.
Lucia: 具有实用价值
Shure: 对非非常具有实用价值
Shure: Yeah, it's super practical.
Shure: 然后如果
Shure: And if...
Shure: 如果哪位哪位同学想过来住一住的话
Shure: If any of the students want to come over and stay...
Shure: 也也也是不介意的
Shure: we wouldn't mind at all.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 然后而且有这么多枕头
Lucia: And there's so many pillows.
Lucia: 就是大家想着枕头大战也是可以的
Lucia: So, if you want a pillow fight, that's also possible.
Shure: 12345最多配5
Shure: 12345, a maximum of 5
Shure: 个同学一起来
Shure: students can come together.
Katrina: 赶紧走
Katrina: Hurry up, let's go.
Katrina:  好可怕这个人
Katrina: This person is so scary.
Jake: 这个这个得团队讨论一下
Jake: The team needs to discuss this.
Jake: 要不要毙掉
Jake: Whether to reject it.
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake: 给我们增加了一些工作量挺好
Jake: It adds some work for us, which is good.
Shure: 就一进门这东西就开始哔哔哔哔哔
Shure: As soon as you enter, this thing starts beeping like crazy.
Jake: 好那我们今天就这样明早见
Jake: Alright, that's it for today. See you tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 下班
Katrina: Time to clock out.
Jake: 下班下班
Jake: Clock out, clock out.
Shure:  下班拜拜
Shure: Clocking out, bye.
Jake: 拜拜放这吧
Jake: Bye, just leave it here.
Katrina:  再见了赛博人生
Katrina: Goodbye, cyber life.
Lucia: 等一下conplete一下
Lucia: Wait a minute, let me complete this.
Jake:明天早上
Jake: Tomorrow morning.
Jake:呃大家把礼物准备一下
Jake: Uh, everyone get your gifts ready.
Jake:然后有一个沙雕小游戏
Jake: Then we'll have a silly little game.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:来规定一下顺序吧
Jake: Let's decide the order.